it went for like three hours and it was
like it was fine had some kind of hiccup
in the internet the inner zone said [ __ ]
no
but it was going good and it was growing
green for like [ __ ] three hours and
all of a sudden straight red went down
to zero kicked us off but we just
restarted it it's good and you can't
blame it on like conspiracy theory [ __ ]
because all we were talking about was
pookie yeah we were talking about poopy
and pooky
right now
she's right there yeah she's laying on
her back and she is
look she looked at my head and i looked
right and looked at her her mind is
blown by daddy's long hair yeah i went
back and looked at like then she went
yeah
she's like looking at him with big eyes
like this like what is this hair about
yeah
and then she was like flirting with the
hair she looked at the bottom of that
yeah she rolled over on her back and she
was like looking at it and the hair was
hanging over the back of the chair and
she looked right at where the end of it
and she got the little narrow eyes like
i'm gonna get that yeah i'm gonna get
that she is really into gotta love his
hair she loves hair honestly she likes
wet hair yeah because when i wash my
hair
and then i
come and play with her like with with
wet hair
she just like stares at it and she's
like we'll eat that yeah and she will
take like the ends of my wet hair
in her mouth and she'll just like
yeah and she just eats it she loves it
yeah i don't understand like why she she
likes the taste of shampoo i guess yeah
i like how we [ __ ] restart the new
stream and tila the first one in line
are we back
yeah we're back we're back taylor
this is the [ __ ] show man we've been
drinking too hard to quit now and we've
only been streaming for three hours
right that's what i mean get these
[ __ ] losers through a whole five-hour
full-ass [ __ ] show like i said it's
friday night
and normally
like you were like well we should do the
show earlier so we can go out afterward
but it's like tonight we're not going
anywhere we're not going anywhere so
we'll roll so it's like i can just
collapse afterwards which is that's
that's fine i don't know i had people
calling me you guys coming out tonight
we went out last friday it was fun man i
got too many goddamn bills man because
we'll go me and jenna go there and spend
120 500 that's what i mean it's like
even though we've drunk at home
by the time we get there i'm like man
i'm sober again i know yeah what i'm not
gonna drink we come back here and we
feel like zombies
and we could take all the [ __ ] weird
and then like the next morning i'm just
kind of like god why do i feel so shitty
i wonder yeah i can start injecting more
testosterone and taking more anavar and
[ __ ] but [ __ ] i don't know man i'm
gonna grow like a [ __ ] beard drove it
yeah okay no i not you're on you're on a
[ __ ] very mild protocol you'll be
fine i know i'm just here yeah i know
i'm not gonna outgrow yeah matter of
fact um uh bee's nest said that he could
tell a difference in you over the past
couple months
he says your face is looking younger you
said that too you and you in the damn
mirror did well when i was at mannequins
younger i don't know if it was just
because i wasn't wearing as much makeup
because i kind of i don't know like
tonight i kind of feel like i look like
an old person but maybe that's because i
don't have bangs
i'm not used to seeing myself without
bangs right
you know what i mean your recom your
recon yeah you're going but wednesday
doesn't have bangs so i couldn't have
bangs she's going through recomposition
she's gaining muscle and losing fat and
so she's getting a little more shapely
in the especially in the legs legs in
the waist area but it takes time it
takes time you're on you're on very mild
hrt hormone replacement therapy
with some other little [ __ ] benefits
that we've done in here and there it
just takes time it's just we're not
trying to transform you into a [ __ ]
power lifter
yeah
it meets the eye
it's just the regular post menopause
style regime that's a regimen
yeah that's that tina says i have two
costume choices none are vampire both
are really nice costumes which one do
none honestly
have you seen ms 45 yeah do the miz 45
none yeah
i've been wanting to do that for a long
time honestly all you need is a nun
costume and a 45 revolver that's all you
need so
people probably wouldn't know the
reference
but see that that is not um
i don't care if people don't know that
because the thing about it is that
i'm more interested in the people that
do know that and like hey you're the
chick from ms45 and then like yeah now
you're my best friend it's kind of
old-school you know what i mean and
[ __ ] i don't know where i don't
really know exactly what tina looks like
i know she's african-american
[ __ ] there are so many good [ __ ]
black characters out there that she
could do that are more contemporary
[ __ ]
that new venom movie had a [ __ ] cool
uh [ __ ] what's her name [ __ ]
shriek or scream what was the name of
that character she looked like a [ __ ]
like a new orleans [ __ ] yeah
gothic mccoy
shriek i think what her name was that'd
be a good character
um
trying to think what else
i don't know i i had i had to see tila
for real to know what character i could
she could run with like that see what
her body composition is like what she
looks like in the face mango says ms45
is a great film it is
that is actually my favorite abel
forever miss 45 i love driller killer
too yeah i'm not saying that but miss 45
god damn that's that movie is so [ __ ]
good miss 45 was a little [ __ ]
dark-haired pale [ __ ] italian chick
though
uh she's not
italian no okay
abel ferrero is from new york new york
that was like a whole that was in new
york but that was that was a cool look
it's just yeah i don't know
tila doesn't probably look like she's uh
man uh what was her name zoe something
she wouldn't uh she wouldn't italian
though
i'm not even sure how tall tila is tila
might make a good storm
but seriously if you haven't seen ms 45
yeah go see mrs martin yeah uh i think
shutter just added it
actually now that i'm thinking about it
because before it was like kind of hard
to find i had it on dvd from like a long
time ago i think it was on 2b for a
while but i think shutter just added it
like a week ago yeah because i was super
jazzed
yeah tina's saying she wanted to be a
kasha akasha would be good for [ __ ]
interviews oh that's a good one too yeah
that's a good one yeah
it's queen of the damned that'd be good
see i think like you always kind of say
well nobody would know what that was or
that's like kind of obscure but see
that's
the that's the fun of doing the costume
yeah
because you want to like go someplace
and the one person that recognizes it
you're like
you're my best friend for life now yeah
like i said i don't give a [ __ ] if like
dumbass people don't recognize it who
cares so i'd actually like to play the
[ __ ] i'd like to like to play the
[ __ ] character from saturn five the
one the [ __ ] harvey keitel did what
was that brother's name
make that damn green [ __ ] space suit
gee that would be great and that would
be great i had to get a wig with a
[ __ ] with that [ __ ] ponytail
what was what was his name ah man
i can't remember now have you ever taken
any blues this is this is blues what was
the name of those pills yeah
blue dreamers
yeah that's right why are you laying
with that old man that kind of [ __ ] you
know
his young flesh
yeah yeah hit your young flesh against
his old flesh that's disgusting
[Laughter]
see that'll be [ __ ] awesome like i
said don't worry about like if other
people get it or not
one of my
dream halloween costumes i
i thus far have not been able to realize
it because i don't have the money
i want to be
the chick from dagon
yeah yeah one in the wheelchair yeah
yeah with the tentacles and the green cr
and the gold crown and everything yeah
absolutely one percent of people would
know what that was yeah but that is
totally fine with me yeah
that's my aspirational halloween costume
oh and also we talked about this like a
couple years back
we wanted to be
uh claytus
and general kala right
yeah general column from
flash gordon
and i kind of looked into it one year we
i looked into it and i was like man i
really want it to look good but it would
have cost
a really lot of money like to do it
because if i'm gonna do it
it's gotta look good it's gonna be exact
it has to look good yeah and it would
cost a lot of money to do collar but i
still wanna do it yeah you would think
well clydus's costume would be hard to
make he had that bronze
mask that gold mask
yeah but actually kala's outfit would
have been even harder because she had
these little plastic
those long plastic beads what did they
call that plastic they called that
plastic it was like some it was like
[ __ ] oh what do you call i know like
i looked it up it was like
yeah yeah yeah it was almost kind of
like uh not what do you call it lycra no
no uh no it's not like that's like
expanding that [ __ ]
but it was um you had to make that whole
headdress and that whole collar
and if you looked at what her collar was
it was long strings of hard plastic
that made that and i forgot what they
called that [ __ ] they were almost kind
of like that opalescent yeah they were
they were [ __ ] shiny black and cl
black and clear
with gold trim you'd have to make that
whole costume it would take a long time
it would be thousands
to make a collar a colin klein because
like i said if you're gonna do something
like that it has to be exact you gotta
do it right yeah you gotta do it right
i'm not one of these like half-assed
[ __ ] right if you're gonna do
that you gotta [ __ ] do it
and
um and those outfits were gothic as [ __ ]
they were gothic as [ __ ] i love that
general clydus or [ __ ] clitus was
[ __ ] cool head of the secret police
and [ __ ] yeah trying to get ming's
daughter yeah we talked about that a
couple years back oh my god we should
totally do that yeah but then i looked
into how much it would cost i'm like oh
maybe we should a couple thousand each
so expensive yeah
but you know uh mango says the hearse
driver from burnt offerings would be a
good one you gotta be six foot [ __ ]
five though you gotta be like really
tall and skinny yeah
oh
that would be a good idea if you're
really tall and skinny though you could
totally pull that off
but you have to be like super creepy you
have to have like sunglasses
that's a good idea though something from
the old dune
one of the harkonnen soldiers or
freaking one or [ __ ] something from
this from a benny jesser at which
something like that oh [ __ ] i didn't
think about that yeah you have to shave
your head for that though
oh
i'm i'm on board i can do those women
had [ __ ]
receding hairlines shaved into their
heads
hair grows back yeah it does and
honestly my hair is so annoying
many times that i've thought of like man
if my head was better shaped i would
just shave this [ __ ] up because it's
just like so i'm just like clogging up
the drains at this point
uh with this stupid hair so you know she
was making her second drink
your second one oh my god this is like
my fourth one or eighth one if you're
going by doubles this is my eighth one
i don't know like i said i'm i'm like
really into
i don't know i kind of like these people
that are really deep into like horror
movies and they will find this kind of
obscure character that has this like
really cool look and they'll reproduce
it
at great expense
and they don't even care if like people
know what that is or not yeah there's
like something pure about that that's
another whole cosplay stuff like i said
i'm a dork like that i'm a horror dork
and it's like i'm honestly really
impressed
when i go to say a convention or i see a
picture online and it's like somebody
went to great lengths to reproduce
this character that maybe only five
percent of the population would know who
that was yeah you know what i mean so
i'm not super worried about
oh it has to be recognizable to a
general audience because [ __ ] that i
don't know i don't give a there's one
costume i can do that i almost have done
all i need is the mask and i need the
[ __ ]
the [ __ ]
dispenser system [ __ ] i can do bane
the the oh the animated bane yeah he's
like the black the black outfit with the
look almost like a wrestler mask and
[ __ ] only is that mask and i need that
thing that he has on his back that with
the glowing green [ __ ] steroids in it
that makes him huge it makes him bigger
i could do bane right now yeah that
would be cool i have i have most of the
shirts the pants and the boots i need a
spiked collar that's nothing
um
i need to make gauntlets that's nothing
um probably buy and and the mask you can
buy several versions of bane's wrestling
mask like i want i want a luchadori
version of [ __ ] bang
you haven't seen the the black anime
version
yeah like that i could do that
and then um
the the mercenary version from the movie
that'd be easy to do i got plate
carriers that could do some of that [ __ ]
but i probably they do make
reproductions of that vest that he has
they're not that expensive
i just don't know how cheap they look
they probably look [ __ ] cheap if not
i just make that but those pants
yeah i just get some [ __ ]
what's the name of that [ __ ]
company
um going to the knee pads installed in
them they're a couple hundred bucks for
those [ __ ] pads
and um
yeah that mask they they make that
[ __ ] face mask because i'm already
bald
do a couple cycles of dianaball i'll be
that size
practice that voice
oh my god taylor has a great idea sheila
says
i want to see a buffalo bill costume at
a party tuck and go oh yeah yeah all you
needed was kind of like that wig
would you [ __ ] me
yeah and kind of like a a robe type
situation and then you could just be
like uh naked
yeah so you'd have to be like adult
party i get it but you know what i mean
yeah um somebody also down here had a
really cool uh camp guy said angus grim
carrying a casket oh actually
anything from phantasm that'd probably
be a good [ __ ] outfit too but like i
said you have to be kind of tall and
skinny to pull that off
mango says
holy [ __ ] i didn't know this peter
wingard played clydus
yeah he rocked he was a peter wingard
also
in he played peter quint in the
innocence
he was also from 1961 which i just did a
review of earlier turn the screw
he was also he was also in uh blood on
satan's claw he was also in seven
voyages of sinbad or one of the sinbad
yeah he was
yeah
yeah that's what i mean it's like [ __ ] i
just like i said i did a review of the
innocence yeah
and
we haven't done blood on satan's claw
yet
have you seen him blood on sentence i
was happy to introduce the the uh the
old classic british [ __ ] sinbad
movies to tila i don't think she'd ever
seen this
i love all that yeah i love that [ __ ] i
don't know tina did you get through all
three movies did you get the [ __ ]
sinbad in the eye the tiger that was a
[ __ ] good one too the [ __ ]
sorceress and the minotaur
tom
i saw that on the thing kill him
at all yeah i saw him in the theater as
little kids that was star wars before
star wars i was like oh wow what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] ogres with
cyclops ogres with horns out of one head
that would have had like [ __ ] goat
feet
fighting giant
giant saber-toothed tigers that had
stripes on them like a siberian tiger
and [ __ ] mechanical minotaurs made by
sorceresses and little homunculus and
[ __ ] and tom baker [ __ ] like oh man
doctor who's in this one you know i was
[ __ ] loving it
[ __ ] loving it yeah i was really into
that when i was kid yeah
can't not get away yeah the br the brits
could deliver back in the day man with
[ __ ] special effects those [ __ ]
british
studios are really good at that you know
they could uh they did it and [ __ ]
they did it so much better than the
[ __ ] americans could do it you know
george lucas went there to do star wars
and a lot of other movies wow do that
[ __ ] in hollywood like i said
i kind of feel like and this is a
generalization obviously even [ __ ]
even alien one was british but i do kind
of feel like the brits like took the
[ __ ] more stuff it took a lot more
seriously yeah it was more like an art
form
acting as an art form special effects in
an art form hollywood they were just
kind of like well what kind of schlock
could we pull off from yeah yeah
like not that much money who wants to be
in this picture has she casted couch did
have i had her on the couch yet oh then
she can't because she have nice boobies
yeah yeah yeah that's all they care
about
although that was awesome
that was a hammer thing yeah yeah does
she have nice boobies yeah yeah
holly was fake as [ __ ] hollywood's still
[ __ ]
it takes a [ __ ] spaniard to come in
and give us [ __ ]
blade runner and [ __ ] dune you know
what i mean i thought he was french i
thought he was spanish
he's a european
i mean i'm pretty sure his name is
french yeah that's a very french name
yeah although i do have to hand it to
um some of the superhero stuff the
americans got to suit some of the super
hero stuff right i'm not a big fan of
the marvel i like dc better than that
new trailers i've seen for that new
batman the batman
that looks [ __ ] good that has like
robert pattinson in it and honestly
didn't think that was going to be any
good that looks good well more power to
him because he kind of got typecast
because he was in the twilight movies
yeah i'm not going to judge him like
look he wanted a paycheck we're all
trying to like make money i'm not
[ __ ] on him for that um and he was
also but he was in some good [ __ ]
movies too he was in the lighthouse yeah
and he was awesome in that so i'm not
gonna like yeah [ __ ] so he was in some
weird [ __ ] after that
so
all right hey oh wow it looks good it
looks good it looks it's like a gritty
batman not technology dependent he's
just a mother he's got a down muscle car
coming at you
good old muscle car and a [ __ ]
homemade looking batman outfit
and then when they show
little [ __ ] what's the name zoe
kravitz as [ __ ] catwoman i'm like
yeah okay this is gonna be good because
she she's that little [ __ ] thing is
so [ __ ] cute and and they went they
went there she said mad max fury road
yes she was yeah they already went the
michelle pfeiffer [ __ ]
catwoman she was [ __ ] great i love
pfeiffer's catwoman but they didn't go
the earth the kit direction so they're
going to put [ __ ] a zoe in there because
you guys gotta get i don't know if you
guys are old to remember eartha kitt was
a [ __ ] badass but a [ __ ]
[ __ ] cat woman too back honestly i'm
a big fan of eartha kids
not just as catwoman but like you know
have you heard like any of her like
music
yeah like all of her she was cool she
was a real cool entertainer yeah she's
way ahead of her time she was kind of
just like a woman of the world i had
some of her like songs on my iphone yeah
that was golden golden arrow yeah it was
a different era
and uh but no the [ __ ] bring zoey in
here [ __ ] now some some i got a
hollywood friend that says i don't know
i don't think it's going to work out
with her
he i think he wanted to go more in the
in the michelle pfeiffer direction and i
was like i don't know man
fury road was [ __ ] badass she really
impressed me in fury road
and you got the [ __ ] eartha kit
[ __ ] background of a [ __ ] catwoman
catwoman could be either race that's not
a race swap
she she was black and she was white you
know either way and [ __ ] yeah
put [ __ ] zoe in there
and um it the the on-screen chemistry
that i saw between the two
in the
in the trailer i was like yeah that's it
that's it i think it's gonna be great
we'll just have to see like i said i
wasn't sure about it and like i said i
don't really mean to like you know [ __ ]
on robert patterson because i know
that
i feel bad for him because he kind of
came to prominence in the twilight
movies which are kind of widely reviled
at least from a critical standpoint
i mean the books were bad i didn't see
the movies
but
i mean you know
i get that he took those just for like a
paycheck
and you know he's a sparkly vampire it's
fine
but
i've seen him in other [ __ ] since then
and it's kind of like um
i i kind of think of them the same way
that i think like daniel radcliffe who
grew up as a kid like in the harry
potter movies so everybody was like oh
he's like harry potter but then when he
got older he's like yeah i have like all
the money now so i can do whatever i
want so he was like in all these like
weird ass movies like horns which was
based on like joe hill and i was kind of
like
that's cool like i respect that you're
actually an actor and you want to like
be like look i have all the money now so
i don't have to like give a [ __ ] whether
this movie fails or not so i can just be
in what i want to be in and i kind of
feel like that's what robert patterson
is doing and
i'm kind of like i'm kind of psyched
about it like i saw the trailer and i
was kind of like man
yeah he looks actually really good as
batman i didn't know how i felt about it
but
i don't know i saw the like i loved the
lighthouse and he was great in that and
he's been in some other [ __ ] since then
that you know he's actually an actor
he's not just the dude that was in
twilight i kind of feel like the same
[ __ ] happened to kristen stewart and
i've seen her in some other [ __ ] because
i know a lot of people [ __ ] on her
because of the twilight movies like oh
she looked real wooden and stuff but
she's been in other stuff where she was
actually really good so
yeah it's hard to judge just from those
movies because those movies were not
great t said hurting her husband her
hubby saw all the uh sinbad movies that
we recommended she loved them [ __ ]
they said they were great said yeah i
thought they were good too and then
she's talking about zoe and she says
she's making a good camera i think so i
agree
i just
like i said my i had very
low expectations for the batman
i just i thought that was gonna suck
but i think on the back of what happened
with the joker they knew that they could
not half-ass it with the batman
and they're kind of showing a batman we
were talking about
up at denny's back in the [ __ ] 80s
before i joined the army granthar's
probably there at the time me and some
of the other little punk rock kids that
were hanging out there they were listen
they were reading [ __ ] illustrated
novels of the batman they were new back
in the latest
86 87 i think it was called the dark
knight that they were reading and they
were saying batman is not supposed to be
a good guy per se he's not ultra rich
it's gritty the [ __ ] had a
shotgun and he had a regular kind of car
and he was
shooting people and he was getting hurt
and everything you know and he didn't
have unlimited money you can't have he
was like the he was a vigilante kind of
like you know something out of death
wish and i was thinking about it and i
was going yeah that would be kind of
cool because they had just made that
movie with the tim burton movie of
batman yeah you know so 89 yeah first
one around that time they were
complaining about that
so i guess it was after i got out of
high school i wanted to move back there
they were complaining about that [ __ ]
and i was going uh yeah maybe that would
sound good well this this is the batman
that they were talking about
you know and i saw that trailer and i
was like man
that looks pretty good yeah that dude is
not [ __ ] jacked he's not [ __ ] huge
but we already had batman like that we
had a pretty big batman and illustrated
ones you know i mean then we had [ __ ]
the dude did the dark knight which i
really liked that one
the [ __ ] tim burton batman that dude
wasn't physical at all
that was michael keaton michael keaton
you know [ __ ] michael keaton was a great
batman yeah but you could beat michael
keaton up you know i could beat michael
keaton that's that's okay you could beat
michael keaton
so but this this batman especially now
because he's a lot older than me
he could beat michael keaton up back
then but [ __ ] um he just wasn't
physical
um so but you don't need to be it's all
about presence and it's all about
charisma yeah it's gotta be kind of
believable you know i mean back that
dude
and they're showing him [ __ ] whip ass
on five dudes like it's nothing
uh you know i mean it has to you have to
have some semblance of [ __ ] realism
there and teresa says christian bale was
a good batman i agree i think he was
good he was actually a great batman he's
a good batman i like that one um but
this guy here he's a little more slender
and but
i think he's going to make a good batman
because you could do it that way too he
might just be very evasive
you know what i mean and quick and we
don't know what kind of weapons he's
using you know he might be more of a
martial artist type
and using stealth and surprise we'll
just have to see but from what i saw in
the trailer i was like yeah okay
all right i'm gonna give it a chance it
looked good and zoey looked [ __ ]
great she looked great i go yeah that's
catwoman
got to earth a kid style catwoman so
let's bring it on my mind is open i want
to see it i want to see it
dj maniac says all you need to be batman
is a jawline and a voice
i'm going to disagree and a presence
yeah yeah kind of like a charisma but
you all you know
christian bale
he could transform himself he could go
from [ __ ] super skinny like in in in
the mechanic or he could he could bulk
up so i could kind of buy the christian
[ __ ] watch the mechanic you guys it's
so good i could buy the christian bell
could whip three dudes his asses real
quick especially in a damn armored suit
with with some technology
michael keaton but the thing is though
is that it worked in the michael keaton
versions because those were cartoon
movies
well and michael keaton has so much
personality and charisma that it's
almost kind of like it overrides
everything else tim burton style cartoon
fantasy movies that's why it worked it
but the um the dark knight series was
supposed to have a little more realism a
little more grit to it
so you you
keaton wouldn't have worked for that you
had to have somebody who could deliver
my only criticism of the [ __ ] the
dark knight is that
some of the voice acting that [ __ ] he
did was a little over the top all right
some of it was a little too much you
know but
i understand that [ __ ] raz al ghul
told him that theatrics was a [ __ ]
great psychological weapon which it is
it is
you know what i mean anybody in special
forces or rangers will tell you it's a
big difference between [ __ ] just
attacking silently somebody else and
then attacking [ __ ] screaming your
[ __ ] head off into some kind of war
cry
with guns blazing because that'll
that'll [ __ ] rattle you a lot worse
than some dude who's just doing it
silently at close range but either will
work it depends on the job depends on
the job depends on what you're doing
well like i said it depends on the whole
tone of the movie like what are you
trying to like what's the effect that
you're trying to achieve yeah uh that
kind of like dictates what actor you're
going to choose for you pour you know
drink sure okay
um
mango says julie newmar was the best cat
woman she was good too i liked her
yeah
honestly i'm not gonna argue with you
about that because she was an awesome
cat like i like michelle pfeiffer's
catwoman i liked all the other
catwoman's but yeah i i see what you get
in the job yeah
um you know i'm not real super invested
in like the batman series
so i don't know if i have an
i don't know i don't know if i had an
opinion about best batman because like i
said it's kind of like it depends on
what kind of batman movie you're doing
are you doing a tim burton batman are
you doing like a gritty serious batman
you know i'm kind of curious to see
i actually didn't give a [ __ ] about it
but then when we went to see um what was
the last movie we went to see
the
when we went to see dune
they had a
a trailer for the batman
which is the first time that i had seen
thank you
uh robert patterson or pattinson or
whatever the [ __ ] his name is
which is the first time that i've seen
the trailer for him is the batman
and i was like oh yeah that's right he's
playing batman and these new ones and i
was kind of like oh hey that looks
pretty good
that looks pretty good i don't even like
thought about it but it looked pretty
good what i liked about it is that his
suit didn't look real high-tech it looks
like a handmade kind of suit he's the
same thing with his car and like i said
cadillac i kind of feel bad for that
dude because
he made all like i don't feel that bad
for him because he made all the money
but he made all the money
being a sparkly vampire in the twilight
series
and
i get it like you gotta make money
somehow
i understand
um but
i don't give a [ __ ] well yeah you get
typecast as that yeah so i respect that
he made all the money doing that and
then he's like you know what i'm just
gonna do like some other weird ass
movies nowadays because he is actually a
good actor like i said we saw him in the
lighthouse and i'm like oh my god he was
amazing in that i didn't see that i
didn't see that vampire what's it called
true blood twilight twilight
no true blood is good that's a that's a
series yeah i didn't see twilight
but uh i saw that movie that had that
girl from twilight wasn't it twilight
when she christened sewer kristen
stewart and she was what was the name of
that [ __ ] movie
she's been a lot of she was in that one
that was kind of like alien they were
underneath the water yeah yeah
underwater that's what it's called right
i own it on blu-ray i love that movie
underwater yeah and that's great she got
that too because i kind of feel like she
was sitting on her and i was like what
are you talking about that was a [ __ ]
great movie if you give her the right oh
my goodness pokemon leave it alone if
you give her the right and i think the
same thing is uh true and it's kind of
shitty because
i know what happens like something
that's like twilight it's so culturally
massive that everyone's gonna be like
associate with that with you like your
whole life
and they're like look i'm just an actor
that's just a job i get a paycheck it's
like they made a lot of money from it
but
that it shouldn't define their whole
career and it's kind of sad that it does
and i get why that happens but
i mean kristen stewart i've seen her and
other [ __ ] she was in that movie about
the runaways and she was [ __ ] great
um you know people like [ __ ] on her
because in the twilight movies
everybody's like oh she's so wooden and
[ __ ] like that but
i think that might have been
because of the story or the director or
whatever the [ __ ] the problem was
because i've seen her in other [ __ ] and
she's awesome
so
well
i don't think that was just her and like
i said i don't think it was a case of
like robert patterson or pattinson or
whatever
being in twilight
you know he was in that but it's like i
i think that was just like um
the movie
because i've seen him and other [ __ ] and
he's fantastic
so he can't act
it's just
a lot of it has to do with like script
and
director and a lot of others how they
feel about the [ __ ] and how they feel
that maybe they're not like super happy
about being they're like look i'm just
here for the paycheck please leave me
alone i get it i thought she was great
in underwater i liked that movie i would
like to see a sequel to
underwater um
it would she won't be in it because she
gets killed in it
but it was kind of like
it was it felt kind of like alien but
underneath the water but it was more
about like
lovecraft
cthulhu
it is very love crafty indiana yeah and
way down deep is kind of like from the
same universe that blade runner an alien
would be in like a like a futuristic
industrial world
and
i just i just enjoyed the movie i
thought she i thought she did great in
it that was such a good movie yeah and
the quality of the movie was and it was
one of those ones that like i kind of
feel like well they dumped in like
january yeah which is the time that it's
like yeah these movies we don't give a
[ __ ] about that we don't think are going
to do very funny it was actually really
good people kind of like yeah blew it
off but i heard that over the years it's
kind of built a cult following that
people are like no that's a good one
which i get because that was a good
movie yeah i think we saw it a couple
times a couple times in the theater like
we went to see it twice on [ __ ] it
was good i thought i had a really good
time with that movie yeah it was fun it
was like really scary it was really
tense it was like people say oh it's an
alien rip off but it's like
everything's a ripoff everything's been
done everything's been done okay it's
the 21st century everything you had
good special effects just entertained me
that's all i had special effects it felt
like a real world yeah it didn't feel uh
fake
um
good young characters um working on
under
underwater
platform
like a mining rig weird [ __ ] happened
um timmy was saying oh well that's like
that's like uh what was it
under what what the abyss and i was like
the james cameron
which was good i saw that in the theater
but so all movies in space are flash
gordon now all movies in space are
[ __ ] that's what i mean like i said
[ __ ] what are you talking about
everything's been done everything's been
done get over it yeah everything
everything has been done 2 000 years ago
yeah everything yeah so
get over it
just like relax new doesn't really enjoy
some [ __ ] when you get to be [ __ ] in
your 50s you realize that new doesn't
exist
yeah i kind of feel like now that i'm
old
[Laughter]
in a way it's weird because it's it's
kind of like i feel like you enjoy stuff
more you're younger but in a in a lot of
ways
i think i appreciate stuff more now that
i'm old because i'm like look i've seen
it all at this point
so
you're kind of to a point where it's
like well everything's been done so i'm
just like looking for new spins on it
yeah you know what i mean if you can do
like some new spin as long as you
entertain me
that's all i seriously that's all i want
cam guys says you want to entertain it
even though i've heard it's a hard plot
to understand i just watched inception
again it made a little more sense yeah
and 10 it kind of came and went real
fast
uh it was supposed to be a huge
blockbuster but the timing was [ __ ]
bad with the cove and all the other
[ __ ] i was waiting for it to come on
and then the [ __ ] pandemic hit
although i heard a lot of good reviews
yeah actually that one missed the boat
and it kind of actually like the
trailers looked good so i kind of wanted
to see this telling so stay away from
tita's telling mango about to stay away
from zoe you don't need that
i don't know exactly theresa is asking
uh if she's 53 is that old
uh
no well i'm middle aged by today's
standards i'm 49
yeah um you are what 50 52 152 52 i
think i'm 52 i think so i don't like to
think of that as old it probably is but
i would never call you old seriously not
thinking about it my cousin says i'm not
old she goes god you're you're that old
but you're not old and this is yeah well
i kind of took cameras you know
the definition changes when i say old
i'm talking about like attitude i'm not
talking about age
tina said she had enjoyed underwater too
a good heroine yeah
i mean it was a it was just really good
it was good because
one i gave a [ __ ] about all the
characters yeah i didn't want them to
die survival adventure and then when
they did die i was bummed out it was
also simple it was survival adventure
they didn't [ __ ] give you a whole
bunch of information you didn't need and
it's just them trying to get through
some [ __ ] [ __ ] that happens at the
bottom of the ocean yeah that's gonna
like [ __ ] resonate with me because
that
that's one of the things that like
that's one of my scare triggers
you're talking about zoe and zoe's
[ __ ] parents and everything lenny
kravitz and lisa bonnet so
zoe's got [ __ ] fantastic genetics
she's she you know she comes from two
superstar
good-looking parents you know that
chances are the way jeans work
is that she's going to pop out the
male or female she's going to
she probably yeah being being being a
superstar you know i mean acceptable
genetics
and um
no i like zoe i like that now now those
young you know what i mean some people
are saying well what she said on social
media this is way way she acts and she's
[ __ ] young all right and she's in
[ __ ] hollywood and
they gotta say crazy [ __ ] all those
hollywood people say crazy [ __ ] i don't
think they i don't think they believe
half of what they say a lot has to do
with the [ __ ] companies that they
work with paying them to say [ __ ]
they're walking advertisements i don't
believe anything [ __ ] most
celebrities say humbly none
they [ __ ] bullet they they they just
do it they're they're they're working a
job they're a brand that's all it is
so you
i don't care what your opinions are
about what people say whether you like
it or don't like it chances are it's not
true anyway they're actors they lie
okay
what did i say something
oh i don't know it's like you just said
something and you were like leaning back
like like you said something like
profound yeah i don't [ __ ] believe in
what actors say they lie
yeah but nobody does no they lie they
say whatever they say whatever they have
to say
i don't really um
i don't know i don't pay any attention
yeah honestly i just watch movies and
read books and
enjoy them yeah jenny that probably
doesn't even know what i'm talking about
but i do actors [ __ ] lie they like
comments i do but it's like it's not
something that super concerns me like i
know that like you won't see the movies
of certain people because of certain
things well no i get that and like i get
that like
i get
that
like people believe what arnold
schwarzenegger says
[ __ ] arnold schwarzenegger [ __ ] is a
troll that [ __ ] was born
trolling
has talked [ __ ]
and [ __ ] basically kind of lied
since he was a kid showing up in the
hollywood scene people would ask [ __ ]
arnold
how'd you get so big
you know you're working out but i work
out how did you get so big because this
is what you do
you take a couple drops of dish water
after you wash the dishes and you put
that in your coffee and drink that
that's what i do and then you take this
hard-boiled egg and you stick it right
up yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] and and
and people would believe him
[ __ ] it's because [ __ ] arnold
didn't want to say well there's this
thing called primo bowling
i'm on drugs y'all yeah there's this
thing called prima bowling and he didn't
want to say that yeah right so
yeah deanna baldwin primo bowling all
right [ __ ] to work out eat a whole
bunch of [ __ ] chicken breasts and
[ __ ] you'll get a huge
[Laughter]
so like i said people back then trolling
trolling and they always troll and lie
and trolling lie and [ __ ] they you
know
don't believe what they say
you know
arnold his [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then that [ __ ]
where's the governor for a while like i
said trolling even after that that
[ __ ] trump the thing about it
and this is going back to something we
said earlier
everyone's an individual yeah so don't
listen
don't necessarily like you should listen
like experts if they know what they're
talking about to an extent
but
you are you
you know what works for you
um
if somebody else is saying some [ __ ]
like hey do this and do that the other
thing
don't take that
just
at face value no you can pay a
[ __ ] to say anything
because you don't know like i said i
just
and the thing about it is like there's
like oh i did this and that and i did it
and you know and it's like but
yeah but i'm not you
i'm gonna come at you this way people
are yeah yeah he's gonna come at me this
way
i'm going to talk about something that i
know that just for sure and this is a
lot of like the instagram
fitness scene you have all these [ __ ]
people when you're looking they look
[ __ ] amazing look at greek statues
all right and they'll tell you [ __ ]
oh hell no i'm not [ __ ] on anything
i'm [ __ ]
drinking this protein powder with
creatine what this is
this is what they hate him to say that
yeah
and they're like and it's my label okay
so when you buy this that's their
sponsor or they own it because you can
you can make that through china and put
your own label on it all right that is
not what made that [ __ ] that
girl or that man look like that okay if
it's a girl that shits anavar all right
that's what you need to look for anavar
and avar or they inject small amounts
appropriate amounts of testosterone the
men are on some [ __ ] [ __ ]
like prima baldwin usually prima bowling
uh some of them will even do trembling
okay if they can [ __ ] manage that
they're all on trt yeah testosterone
drugs
drugs no so any kind of like
diet supplements or anything like that
that is not doing that no no no no no
that's not all kinds of drugs and
hormones well they're hormones okay some
of them are drugs but
they're mostly synthetic hormones
that if you take that [ __ ] and work out
and eat a certain way your body will
respond instantly and you'll make 10
years of gains in the [ __ ] year
all right that pro that powder all these
[ __ ] powders they laugh at those
powders
those are the powders that they sell you
okay those powders have little [ __ ]
creatine no
protein you they're eating protein
but that's not what's making them
[ __ ] huge
they're working out and they're taking
[ __ ] anabolic steroids and people
have known this [ __ ] going back to the
[ __ ] 50s
you just know how
and you do too much of that [ __ ] to
[ __ ] blow your heart up they [ __ ]
dead by the time they're [ __ ] 35
there's limits to what the human body
could do
there aren't much limits to what [ __ ]
steroids can do though steroids that
make you big enough to kill yourself
you'd be dead a year later you better
[ __ ] watch it okay
um but you know
if you're [ __ ] chilled out with a
[ __ ]
you can run a lot you can run [ __ ]
girls for long one thing they do a lot
too yeah and they talked about this on
uh if you any of you guys have seen penn
tellers [ __ ] yeah i wish they did i
think it was on showtime
and one of the things they did was all
these kind of like fitness
uh you know infomercials and stuff yeah
and they said one thing that they do
is that
they will get fitness models
who are like on all these drugs and like
their [ __ ] like workout 24 7.
and they come on their shows and they
pay them
to come on and say oh hey i did this
drug or this
you know whatever this uh you know
exercise
exercise
yeah and it's like look and now i look
like this and they're like yeah that's
not
how they got that no um so it's like
really really misleading right
yes they do really look like that but
that's not how they got like i was in a
bar one time jenny was standing next to
me in this [ __ ] dude we were talking
about [ __ ] uh uh [ __ ]
professional bodybuilding
uh remember that black dude was talking
about black dude [ __ ] professional
bodybuilder and i said yeah well there's
all this [ __ ] steroids the [ __ ]
arnold took he goes arnold did steroids
i just looked at him
yeah
yeah what are you talking about they all
did that this was the [ __ ] golden era
for that [ __ ] i know exactly what he
took he was he [ __ ] had a
testosterone base okay so he's taking
trt
and then he took deanna ball
and primable those are the main ones all
right and [ __ ] very high protein diet
and he lifted a lot of weights but the
stigma behind that in the 70s was pretty
heavy they couldn't admit that because
the thinking of the time
of the average person was
oh well you took steroids so [ __ ] it's
cheating it's just cheating and like
that means anybody could do it no sure
no
no not everybody can do it
um
if the average person you give them
steroids and they don't work out they
don't do what they just get fat
okay um
if you give the average person steroids
and they work out they'll get pretty big
they would never get as big as [ __ ]
arnold
those guys had genetics
that allowed them to respond to those
drugs they were what was called hyper
responders
they would respond twice as much as your
average person
and then they had certain genetics in
terms of skeleton size and muscularity
that once they grew [ __ ] big like
that they looked better than
anybody else who would be on those drugs
so it's not just those drugs they also
lifted a lot of weight
a lot
now they were taking a lot of this [ __ ]
too a lot
by the time they were [ __ ] in their
40s they were having heart problems
because they just weighed too much and
it [ __ ] up the heart valves and stuff
it's bad for your cardiovascular system
long term
but had that been a normal person they'd
have been dead by about 25
their genes allowed them to resist
and take all that [ __ ]
acceleration from those [ __ ]
anabolics they were taking lots i mean
that would be considered like three
times what a person today would take
now they're getting even bigger but
they're not just taking steroids they're
also taking [ __ ] like [ __ ] human
growth hormones on top of the steroids
and [ __ ]
um what's the other one insulins the
insulins allow them to [ __ ] take more
there's a lot of [ __ ] tricks there's
huge stacks of drugs they got so big
they're [ __ ] biggest big rammy and
[ __ ] some of these other guys they're
big they're so big they don't even look
good anymore it's gonna go back to
classic bodybuilding which is you know
220 pounds
symmetry looking good not mass mass
doesn't look good
but in the 90s and early 2000s they got
[ __ ] this hard on for the judges
wanted mass
not symmetry and
because it is not a sport it is a beauty
contest
and that's always what it was
mr america mr universe olympia these
were [ __ ] beauty contests
but these macho [ __ ] don't want
to say their beauty because they're
gonna say it's a sport but there's no
[ __ ] rules there's no [ __ ] they
don't have to like do it there's no
score
it's just how good do you look in front
of the judges so it's a beauty contest
and it'd be a lot better if they just
said well it's it's beauty kind of this
you know and it makes a lot more sense
when you look at it that way
but um
yeah
no steroids
steroids they work
but like i said
back in the old days you weren't allowed
you weren't allowed to say that yeah
that you were on steroids he was [ __ ]
you had to like he was amazed arnold
schwarzenegger did steroids uh yes
yeah all those dudes did all those dudes
from the 80s and the 70s were [ __ ]
jacked on that [ __ ]
and
they didn't really know what they were
doing
and a lot of them [ __ ] ended up
looking like fast slobs because
there's certain [ __ ] you got to do
to keep from going that way
and i don't recommend [ __ ] doing what
they were doing at a young age
just just [ __ ] kill you
there's that you can take you know too
much of a good thing you know whatever
you come on it's just [ __ ] extreme
tila says okay why in the hell are they
remaking the exorcist
are they yeah i heard they are remaking
the exorcist of course they are the
thing is about the exorcist uh it's a
perfect film that an exorcist three it's
leave it alone already honestly like
some people like didn't they remake like
they did a prequel
which it was pretty good
but
it'd be like remaking the remaking the
shining you'd have to be real [ __ ]
careful and you'd have to get the right
people involved in that and um if you're
gonna take this down
the uh the road of [ __ ] um
the the conjuring universe
not gonna be good i mean you'll make
some money but it'll never top that
classic
because the exorcist is a slow burn
and it's kind of a psychological horror
and i think a lot of what made the
exorcist great was the timing
that came in the 70s
in a time when religiosity was pretty
low
but the exorcist actually restarted
religiosity in the united states for a
while it was the beginning of the
satanic panic
reminding you remember that was one of
the things that that kind of kicked out
rekindled
worried about the devil yeah
and i don't think that could happen
again
not unless you're a master
that dude who did blade runner the dune
could probably do it
but honestly i kind of feel like
i know they still do some remakes
nowadays
um but i kind of feel like the heyday of
the remakes
was early 2000s yeah they were remaking
all the [ __ ] like from the 70s and 80s
and some of it was okay
but
i didn't love it
i just i don't know i just kind of feel
like
if you want to do something like that
just do something in that same
vein do something with that same vibe
but don't like remake
it
why would you do that we already have
that movie
we already have the exorcist
we already have the texas chainsaw
massacre we already have
the nightmare on the street a nightmare
on the street like what don't remake it
like i understand why they do because
it's like oh you know brand recognition
i understand that
but
from an artistic point of view
i don't really see much point in it
i don't see much point in it honestly if
you want to do something like that just
making like an homage
make an homage to it
because you're not gonna
well some of you you're not gonna top
the original
i think the time has passed for that but
they're trying to do a lot of cash grabs
although like i said nowadays that seems
less a thing i kind of feel like that
was more a thing in like the late 90s
and early 2000s because i kind of feel
like late 90s early 2000s they're like
we're gonna remake all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] from the 70s and 80s they remade
texas chainsaw massacre they were made
they were made pretty much every 80
slasher movie
every 70s movie they've remade all that
[ __ ] it depends on what time frame
they're and they were all bad are they
gonna put this [ __ ] are they gonna
put this exorcist remake in modern days
or is it gonna be back in the 70s
i kind of feel like the way shit's going
nowadays they'll probably do it back in
the 70s that's what i would think
because like i said even nowadays like a
lot of newer horror movies actually are
set in the 70s or 80s because like
pre-cell phones
because when you have cell phones you
have to rewrite
now you see a lot of stuff but i would
do
instead of doing the exorcist
i would have bought the franchise for um
the oven
the omen one two and three and redone
that whole trilogy
for a new era and gone straight full-on
fundamental christian
did whole thing and got the christian
the christian horror
would that work nowadays i think it
would i think it would i don't know i
would [ __ ] go the whole apocalyptic
route
the whole [ __ ] um you know
revelations
uh antichrist i'd have gone the whole
[ __ ] thing and i'd uh um
omen one i would have put that like in
the 70s
when he was born
two yeah three
more two would have been in the 80s and
three would have been like right now
all right when he's like in his late 40s
and he's now the president
and with this with the special effects
of today
you could do that really well but you
have to [ __ ]
tackle that [ __ ] [ __ ] head-on it's
gotta be [ __ ] dead serious
and it has to be like
yeah right out of scripture
that's how i would do it you'd probably
you'd get you'd probably get that whole
[ __ ]
you can get that whole um
um
you could do it like a christian horror
thing yeah you could get it up on pure
flicks yeah you get on pure flicks and
everything
but i would make that [ __ ] rated r
wait do you guys know that pure flicks
exist
yeah it's just nothing it's the
christian christian christian netflix
yeah it's probably terrible
it is but
thank you mr robato yeah tom no little
shop dennis costume i don't know what's
that good job what you should have been
uh you should have had a little shop of
horrors dentist costumes yeah yeah i'll
be it actually i have that
i have that because my chef jacket is
the same thing as that oh you should
have done that yeah my chef jack is the
same as that dennis outfit and i'm
wearing those those pants and that boots
right now i got i got those babies oh my
god you should have done it that's it
there you go with the buckles and [ __ ]
but if you guys don't know um
yeah there's a thing called pureflix
yeah which is like netflix but it's all
christian
movies and series yeah
and
i'm pretty sure i'm not going out on a
limb here i'm saying they're pretty much
all terrible
all the series are made by what's that
dude's name david r white
and
he's behind a lot of the series on it
and they're like so okay so it's this
level of
we're gonna film [ __ ] like in a studio
and then they buy
like they film it in front of a green
screen
and then they buy like backgrounds yeah
from you know yeah yeah and so like they
buy backgrounds from like stock photos
so the problem with the christian movies
is they don't have the budget and they
don't have the talent okay but if we did
like mel gibson did the [ __ ] one with
the damn jesus what was the one that
lasted no
that no that was my last interpretation
that was a good movie had devoe in it
last
temptation of christ that was willing to
foe right yeah last temptation crisis
that was actually a good one
um what was the one that uh that that he
did
the passion of the passion of the christ
you see
the jesus like horror porn one yeah you
see if you're gonna do if you're gonna
do christian horror it's good for you to
go it's gory you have to go that way you
have to go
with last temptation of the christ
because uh that movie made a [ __ ] ton of
money passion of the christ passionate
passion of the christ last temptation of
christ made
not all not that yeah but the thing is
it was it got good acclaim yeah
well because it was controversial
because i liked it posited i did too
yeah i saw in the theater but it posited
that jesus was a human that had sex
catholics flipped out yeah
but uh honestly i think that's why
i think that was kind of why it got
uh the
press that it did was because catholics
were picketing the theaters
jesus does not have sex
it was this whole thing yeah well it was
a whole thing i don't know i don't want
to talk about that no that's what
happened yeah
it's dumb it's dumb i know it's dumb um
because
catholics and christians don't first of
all they don't understand the ancient
world
they don't know what situation had there
been in jesus they don't really
understand what life he would have lived
he would have had sex well obviously
yeah
and thank you mr robato
they don't know what was forbidden and
what wasn't forbidden they're projecting
their morals and their values on
honestly yes obviously not a person that
supposedly lives 2000 years ago
so i just think it's childish even to
talk about that stuff i really don't
care what christians think i know the
truth behind what those scriptures mean
and what they are i don't believe that
there was a historical jesus they're
always looking at
the jesus that we have in the new
testament is a roman god like dionysus
if there was a historical jesus nothing
of him remains in those scriptures yes i
agree with that yeah so
yeah all that has been edited out
i tend to think there was no historical
jesus i agree with that assessment it's
basically a roman religious cult
that is kind of has a jewish influence
to it
because they were basically roman jews
living in the roman empire coming up
with this they're rebooting judaism it's
a new sect of it
and they're rebooting it as if it was a
roman god to make it friendlier to the
culture that they grew up in which of
rome
it's a roman religion
i don't give a [ __ ] what modern
christians
say or think because they don't know the
facts then they haven't really studied
go to dr robert m price he will and he
was an old priest he will tell you
everything about what it really says and
what it doesn't say they're not really
interested in what it really says this
is their own imagination they're
projecting they want to project their
own that is none of that shit's written
in those scriptures
uh they're taking things way out of
context and
their cons their ideas of what good and
bad is did not apply two thousand years
ago
anyway getting back to what i was saying
about um
if you wanted to make a good christian
horror movie it has to be straight up
rated r it has to go the way of last of
of um
with the gibson movie passion of the
christ where it has to be exciting kind
of like an action movie with a bunch of
gore in it it does yeah because that was
like really gory it does have to
be uh it does have to follow a [ __ ]
scripture so what you do is you take the
story of the omen and the antichrist and
you
um [ __ ] put that against the backdrop
of of [ __ ] this of the book of
revelations and armageddon oh man it
would be awesome if you knew how to do
it if you had the money and the right
director that respected the source
material
you could make a badass omen
flick about the antichrist and i would
watch [ __ ] the revelations and the
apocalypse and it would have to be
canonically
in there and it would just be awesome
but in hollywood studios today you don't
have anybody that has the balls or
really the knowledge to appreciate the
source material if you tell a biblical
story it's got to be with the source
material just like darren aronowski's
[ __ ] noah
beautiful story that's the story of noah
and the story and actual
and the other jewish texts about noah
that's it that is the story is that
movie to me
i mean i'm an a my he's an ass i don't
really care but it's like
that movie to me i'm like that's exactly
what they're talking about that's what
they're talking about that's what they
said it's like something out of debt
they took it right out of the scripture
and and the original story is like
something out of the alien and
prometheus that's exactly what they're
talking about beings from the heavens
enchained into the earth and the rocks
of the earth and mankind and the cities
were rolling up and they're [ __ ]
destroying the earth and [ __ ] uh noah
being the shepherd of the earth and
[ __ ] then you're having
damn
you know not moses but abraham shows up
and he's ancient oh no that's a [ __ ]
great movie we'll see like i said
it just goes to show one
atheists make the best movies about
christian method mythology well they're
impartial well yeah
because
i feel like
a lot of christians who actually believe
in this stuff that's in the bible
if you show them the stuff that's
actually in the bible
they will reject it yeah
because
darren aronofsky noah and i said this is
this is biblical that
was what they talked about in the story
it's right there religious people not
only christians and they had a [ __ ]
fit
all religious people
muslims christians and jews distort
their scriptures through the lens of
faith
because they believe it they start
distorting it and making it something
that it is not
which is
when you you cannot look through
you cannot look at scripture
through the lens of faith you'll distort
it into something your traditions say it
is not what it actually says
that's the problem
when when a christian reads the story of
noah he's distorting that story
through the lens of what they were told
as a child through [ __ ] noah stories
it kind of
that's not exactly what like how many
animals were in
the uh uh the you know
how many animals were in there
most of them will say well a male and a
female no there's seven pair i think it
says different things one of them says
it's
two pair of male and female and now and
i think the other story says what is it
seven pair of male and female clean
animals and like four or five pair male
and female of hundreds how big is this
boat
uh a big well it's not a bow it just
says an ark and an arc is how big is
this arc
oh it get it get like this you know big
big uh like it's
like the size of the queen mary i think
is what they're talking about
and it's not
a boat it just says ark which means box
it's a box though it's a box a floating
box
yeah
but still
yeah so it's not above it's just
logistically logistically yeah it is
unrealistic
it was never supposed to be realistic i
don't think obviously it was never
supposed to be real obviously but
it's just a tourist it's a story you
tell around the campfire
if you ever if you ever and some people
i'm not naming any names but some people
still build whole entire theme parks
based on this being a real thing where
there were actually
two of every kind of animal that were
living at the time
we're gonna put those all in a boat
and that was the thing that happened and
dinosaurs and humans lived at the same
time
and
i don't understand
i don't understand it yeah well but some
people have kind of like built whole
theme parks
these are mythic tales yes
obviously yeah and obviously it actually
goes back to uh you know like the epic
of gilgamesh where the gods decide to
drown out the world yes so it's a
retelling of the epic of gilgamesh it's
very old it's a canaanite version of the
epic
the hebrews were a canaanite tribe these
are all canaanites and they're
worshiping the canaanite gods
um
which are kind of like the egyptian gods
but you know i don't get pent up about
it and the people that believe about it
i don't really care what people believe
about it you can you can listen to any
story and reinterpret it any way you
want it doesn't affect me
i don't make fun of people for being
wrong
uh
even if they're wrong they're getting
comfort from believing in things that
are not true
it's very retro
all that [ __ ] is very retro but it does
it was just they're they're they're
believing in a cultural library of
people that aren't related to them
they're
it's just a story it's just a creation
story and part of the creation story
involved a flood
uh and it is because you know the epic
of gilgamesh had it
and there's evidence everywhere as
ever
evidence everywhere around the middle
east when you climb to the top of the
mountain you'll find seashells up there
so they have to have an explanation
of why the [ __ ] are there seashells on
top of all these mountains
and that's really all it is because that
[ __ ] used to be out because it needs to
be underwater
that's which
but they don't realize that
you don't know about geology yeah you
know and they didn't realize how long
ago that was
that's all it is so they have to explain
why there are sea shells on the tops of
the mountains
all throughout the middle east that's
all it is
which it's a simple explanation for us
but for them that was really [ __ ]
them up they're like
that means the entire earth was
underwater what the hell happened you
know oh my god what the [ __ ] was going
on yeah yeah well we're bad we got
punished a long time ago
which says
god drowned us yeah yeah we got punished
pretty much
but it all worked out though that's
[ __ ] what that's all right so it's
cool yeah that's all it means
but yeah i
yeah like i said this kind of [ __ ]
fascinates me i know it's not true like
no that should happen but
the whole like making of the mythology
fascinates me
well it took place over
many many generations oh yeah
and they just kind of handed it down
uh the rest of the world doesn't have it
you know the chinese and the japanese
they don't really have it well yeah why
would it affect them it's a near east
middle east and european thing well like
i said i kind of feel like a lot of our
myths came from something that happened
but something that happened on a very
very local
uh you know kind of time scale so there
was some little flood that happened
somewhere and it got like blown up like
a game of telephone
and suddenly it was like this big global
whatever
you know what i mean so something that
happened like
on a smaller scale and got blown up to
like a global scale yeah kind of none of
that stuff actually happened they're
they're not really then it happened like
i said it was something that was like
really small and got blown up to like
this big
if you could go you can go to any top
any mountain [ __ ] going around the
gulf of aquaba
[ __ ] which is you know supposedly
where moses was running around you know
trying to
survive him and his people were
wandering through that [ __ ]
desert you know and in the sinai
peninsula outside of egypt they're
wandering around for 40 years eating
mana and [ __ ] right you go to any of
those damn tops of those little
mountains of stan sandstone
and find seashells there and of course
ancient people are going like what the
[ __ ] happened the ocean used to be up
here and you could stand on top of it
because that was [ __ ] hundreds of
feet hundred damn [ __ ] you know what
the hell happened so that's that's
so they have these people must have
really been sinful yeah well they
weren't it's because they didn't they
didn't believe in [ __ ] yah all right
and they weren't [ __ ] they weren't
listening to el shaddai
and he [ __ ] them up
wow tell us how that happened and if you
ever [ __ ] go hang out with better
ones and [ __ ] out in the desert [ __ ]
and you they sit around in the campfire
[ __ ] pass carcade and [ __ ] smoke
shisha which is not hashish it's just
tobacco smoke shisha and they talk and
they ask questions and [ __ ] and then
some old dude go yeah back in the day
y'all said [ __ ] all this [ __ ] he made it
rain for 40 days and night you flooded
the whole [ __ ] how do you think them
shells got up there you guys are bad
we were all bad you know but we survived
you know what i mean our people [ __ ]
believed it y'all we were on the [ __ ]
we were on so that's why we're still
here yeah yeah we were on the ark and we
came out and [ __ ] you know and then
we spread and multiplied you know that's
what they're talking about well
everybody likes to feel like they're
special yeah
everybody likes it you have to have an
explanation for it that's that's what it
is
yeah i know yeah and it wasn't
malevolent or anything they're just
making no i and i get that it's like
it's totally not
like people are not being like like oh
i'm the king of the universe or anything
like that but it's just kind of like
it's a very human thing yeah they're
desert people yeah well it's a very
human thing to think one you're the
center of the universe yeah which you're
not a spoiler alert but also
it's kind of like
well whatever like is happening now
that's kind of like the end product
of this long line of
evolutionary whatever like all this
stuff that happened
which
i don't know
it's like it's it's too much like
self-importance yeah yeah you're having
a problem with that because you kind of
have a background in kind of like
modernity and and towns and villages you
wouldn't feel that way had you grown up
in the sinai peninsula out in the middle
of the desert with a very low population
density with your own local tribal
culture it would be the world and just
you and your family and the friends of
your family and your extended tribe
that's the world and the world was made
for you and god made your people
other people show up you go oh not them
god didn't make those people yeah that's
a yeah
our scriptures say that you know the
[ __ ] that we were the chosen ones and
these are the ones that were not related
to us and [ __ ] you know after [ __ ]
leaving the leaving yeah yeah so no no
it was exclusive they weren't evil it's
just that they're these are country
people out in the desert
it's like some [ __ ] out of doom dune was
based on all that kind of stuff you know
all these civilized [ __ ] coming
here they're savages we're the real
people
you know they're the natives that's
exactly what they're talking about well
i mean
like i said there's evil cities
everybody and then they can say those
evil city people god punishes them look
at what they did the babadra
or sodom and gomorrah same thing
they were all gay [ __ ] them up see but
not us we're straight those butt [ __ ]
we're super straight yeah we're super
straight those people there man you
would never even think about it like
going into a little city
yeah
so that's what they're that's that's
what they're talking about
don't make it something that it isn't
it's not bad or it's it's not bad it's
just
a a a way of [ __ ]
tribal people that are not very numerous
that's the way they think
it's the way you kind of think in
mississippi
yes but i know that right it's that same
thing i know that yeah
but
some of us
me for example yeah have
uh
we don't think like that anymore well
you're a mother but i understand that
like other people do yeah you're a
modern person that has access to the
internet and modern telecommunications
you know about the outside world uh no
these people didn't did not think yeah i
know and i can i can take you
to you know a place in in egypt or in
the santa peninsula and introduce you to
better ones and they're just not in the
modern world yeah i get that and they're
not bad they're friendly
it's just that you know they probably
like that i understand that i understand
that like some people don't have this
whole like
i'm out
i don't know
i don't know if you call like outside of
culture it's called ethnocentrism
you know i mean they're ethnocentric
very ethnocentric yeah and they're not
numerous so therefore they're special
yeah i get that they're like oh yeah
well like i said that's a very human
yeah humans our brains kind of evolve to
be like that yeah when you're not
numerous you go well we're special and
this was all made for us and i mean
people were made for us to look at but
where the you know on the other hand
yeah human brains are capable of
transcending that
uh
i'm gonna say it's a mix that's a mixed
bag
some people can not all of them some
people can't some people can some people
can't but a lot of people can yeah so
i'm not saying there's no excuse
i'm just saying that it's not really our
place to go in there and [ __ ] destroy
those cultures though those are the no i
don't know i don't think we should if
that'd be like going to suck in africa
unless meeting tribal people say you
can't be like this because americans
aren't like this so you can't be like
this
they're not like us they believe in
different ways they see things they're
friendly
uh but no if you you can get into bad
trouble there
okay
in the same way you could have gotten in
bad trouble in salem by talking about
witches and [ __ ] next thing you know you
might although the thing about it is
that
[ __ ] do you want to
okay let's use that as an example let's
say you went back as you know in a time
machine yeah
and
you go back to salem at the time of the
witch trials and where
there's women that obviously did nothing
they're just like innocent women
they were midwives or whatever
and it's like they're gonna be burned at
the stake
are you going to save them
they're innocent how could i
with body technology they didn't do
anything
could you like take them to the modern
era with you i'm just saying if you had
the technology to do that would you do
that because i would uh
yeah probably but the problem problem is
is that if you had modern technology and
they would have stopped it back then to
be with guns which means you had to kill
you had to kill a bunch of them
well and and these are if they were
gonna like burn some innocent people
alive i don't have a problem with that
what do you do you kill five of them to
save one and they're all kind of
innocent because they're all dumbasses
they're fronting from another era right
but you have well in that
okay if you're gonna go that route yeah
you have to kind of go
yeah they're all dumbasses they're all
dumb asses yeah but
and if you can't in the middle of you
try to talk talk them out of it
you could end up no well no you're not
don't talk them out of there because
they're [ __ ] they don't know
so i'm kind of like
from a modern point of view
those dudes back then
they're burning an innocent woman yeah
because of some [ __ ] but yeah
i kind of feel like that woman
she didn't do anything no
probably but you know what would happen
you'd grab that woman and teleport away
with her and she would [ __ ] turn at
you and goes oh my god you're satan you
saved me i'm not a witch it'd be some
[ __ ] like that like you can't but that's
like a warlock or something
maybe
maybe
but the thing about it i don't know i
kind of feel like you get to a point
where i don't know
and another thing you gotta look at
about is what happened in the past
happened with the past you start [ __ ]
around with the past and it could change
the present well i know that there's all
that time i'm just talking about if
you're not gonna like affect anything in
the future i'm just saying if you could
actually go back and like save some
people that for example
were burned at the salem witch trials or
what have you like not they were hanged
actually
that was a european thing burning them
but
obviously none of them were witches
okay
so
those women
probably did nothing
right
i mean obviously did nothing they didn't
do what they were accused of doing
obviously
so
i don't know i kind of feel like
is it really this is like a hard
question now that i'm thinking about it
i don't know i don't feel all that bad
about [ __ ] with the people if i could
like as you know just hypothetically
go back in a time machine if i could
[ __ ] with the people
from that time period
and bring some like women
into the modern era
they might be all right
honestly they might be all right
i don't know you'd have to like give
them a little bit you'd have to give
them some time
to
get whatever how old they were ever get
with the modern scissors yeah they're
older i think people from the 1500s just
would not be able to
not be able to maintain it would depend
on the person it would depend on the
person because some people might be able
to and some people may not you're you're
projecting your sanity and your
intelligence on people that [ __ ] you
don't sure i get that and but
if you were to give you to go back in a
time in the 1500s and get a [ __ ] i
don't know
the [ __ ] english night or some [ __ ]
back from the 1100s you couldn't have
him just walking around here in this
[ __ ] house
and [ __ ] be getting in your bathtub
and [ __ ] splashing all the [ __ ]
water out of this [ __ ] piss and all
[ __ ] and [ __ ] trying to eat your cat
or [ __ ] you know what i mean raping
women and stuff no they were [ __ ]
animals we were talking about it's
pretty much it's pretty no they were
they could get out of it they were worse
than any [ __ ] you know like a local
gangster or some [ __ ] you know i've
actually kind of like i thought about
that
would be to beat them up you'd have to
beat him up into submission to get him
to listen to you that's not who you're
not dealing with a modern person the
medieval mentality was [ __ ] up i
thought about this a lot because he took
cats and [ __ ] tie them together by
the tail and hung them over a lot
wires so they'd fight each other to
death they did they were [ __ ] they
would stake a bear into the ground and
[ __ ] try to set it on fire for fun
you know they were [ __ ] crazy
although like i said i'm just saying to
anybody that is from the past yeah and
would be brought here in the future of
my time machine that i'm going to event
someday yeah um
you try to do anything to my cat yeah
let's try it with matt um
you i'm gonna turn you inside out a
medieval would [ __ ] reach don't touch
my [ __ ] cat
medieval reach down and [ __ ] grab a
half rot and [ __ ] grab her half rot
and [ __ ] rat and stick it in your
face and go smell that that stinks
doesn't it maybe they were [ __ ]
morons although do you think that do
they
they do that nowadays
doesn't that stink you know they're
[ __ ] nervous although like i said
because there was a book and i'm not
lying people there were books that said
this tradition lives on yeah there were
books admonishing people back written
back in the middle of the middle of the
day same please do not pick up dead
things and sniff them okay which meant
that that was a problem
okay and they're like look if you see
somebody being murdered don't laugh at
them you know they [ __ ] said oh yeah
they were they were [ __ ] crazy
well i don't know if it was so much
crazy they just didn't really they
didn't have a modern men's sensibilities
and i guess that's understandable
because after our time
thank you mr abado men and ladies were
tried as witches yeah yeah they were
mostly ladies but some men too
because ladies we're the worst we're
evil but you know it's it's kind of this
whole thing where
i don't know i kind of feel like
the medieval time period
life was very cheap
um a lot of people died young
many people had
several children that died as babies
well it still is so everyone kind of had
to
get with the program of
not caring too much it still is kind of
like that though jenny just depends on
where you live well yeah i know that
like i'm talking about like in the west
it's not really like that but
i know that in some parts of the world
is still like that
but
it was kind of a thing where well
i had like five kids and they died
before they were two
from various ailments
so you couldn't get too attached
to people we had to be hard so i kind of
feel like well
it's not so much hard it was like people
had to be like sociopaths honestly
you had to like not care yeah well it
was a numbers game
yeah well it's like well i can't get too
attached to these kids or this spouse or
whatever because they're probably gonna
drop dead
so yeah
everyone was just very
are you hungry mercenary are you hungry
yeah i got some hamburgers down there i
could make i was throwing them out well
i'm just saying that
thawing out some hamburgers
okay it's about time for a hamburger you
think oh man i'll cook that [ __ ] up the
frying pan
i got those buns and everything that i
bought see i'm trying to talk her down
people what time is it how long we've
been how long how long we've been
streaming on this one
uh hour and 24 minutes that's good so um
we're going to be checking off here
checking off here in a
bit people is there any questions is
there anything you want us to talk about
before we go ahead and end the show
today
this was a fun show i think oh yeah he
had a funny show yeah
he had a fun show even though i wore a
costume and you did not it's see this
she's gonna [ __ ] bust my balls over
this [ __ ] you can buff my balls over
this
if we do a show on sunday which is
actual halloween day yeah you better
wear a costume
sunday if if halloween is sunday then
that is then that means we have to get
candy
yes
and that means you got to put out the
[ __ ] halloween lights
and also get enough candy so like i can
eat some candy let's
see um
yeah they'll probably uh probably i
could get some candy at uh
we'll go to sam's and get some candy
that's probably the best yeah yeah
yeah it'll be some [ __ ] that could pick
up at sam's
candy so good get good [ __ ] yeah well
because if nobody comes here
because our
front legs don't work mango's coming on
down he's jumping on the jet to get the
hamburgers
all the way from england really yeah
you make some hey we're gonna put some
guacamole on it i get what fried eggs
pokemon yeah you want fried it looks
like you got it
duh yeah all right i can do that put a
fried egg on it okay i don't know if i
have any guacamole though well that's
like
if you have something fine but if you
don't i got cheese
got mustard cheese fresh
cheese it's fine too okay
mostly like um i got uh
i got also got tomatoes fresh tomatoes
the big ones
yes i'm into that you want the onion on
it no good
i would get home you want pickles though
right yes okay i got pickles
oh my god i can do that
can you i know
okay i'm gonna shut down people she's
loaded i gotta [ __ ] shut her off so
are you yeah i can control it
you're losing control you're out of
control
i don't know
no looks like you get rid of this
control
when she lose control she gets mad
she'll turn on me and start [ __ ]
wanting to fight
i get mad at you because i start acting
like a douche no no no no it's part of
your hallucinations
it's part of your hallucinations when
you're drunk it's that i'm being a
douche
and it happens in nightclubs and she
attacks me because i'm not dancing
although i haven't done it in a while
though here's the thing though
why aren't you dancing why are you so
lame why are you so [ __ ] why aren't
you dancing i'm like what are we talking
about
well the thing about it though is that
you kind of act like an [ __ ] and then
like if i get upset about it
then you gaslight i act like an [ __ ]
and you're like all right what i'm not
being an [ __ ] i'm not being nasty
i'm like whoa wait a minute i'm drunk
and then the bartender is like okay
yeah i'm okay
it is funny though
it's kind of funny
because i i i know i know your patterns
it's funny
i know your patterns too okay i
understand that i understand
and uh other bartenders also know your
patterns it's okay that's okay
sometimes i'll be so drunk i can't talk
just like yes yeah yeah
and i don't usually we haven't gotten
that point though i haven't gotten that
drunken in a long time let's see what
everybody's talking about
so sending good vibes to y'all that's
what either said
i mean you know
i'm trying to [ __ ]
god damn it khan jumps in and says uh go
see the deep house guys it's different
but okay moving deep house you know
about that one
never heard of the deep house
no no i don't
mango something
jumps in and says feel your pain tom the
honey badger does that same [ __ ] a lot
that same thing a lot yeah
don't forget the dune plant oh yeah yeah
yeah i forgot is that the asylum ripoff
yeah asylum came in with sean what's her
name remember sean
and she's in it
and they posted that in tom shitty's
movies and that's my that's my channel
yeah shitty movies on [ __ ] on [ __ ]
facebook
and they posted the [ __ ] post posted
sean young the dude planet
and it's got the [ __ ] sand worm and
her running across the d and i went and
i came in there says no you guys have
got to be [ __ ] kidding me no asylum
that's their whole business yeah yeah
and they went no man it's for real
every time a big movie comes out
they well they know about it like
previously so like oh let's like knock
off a like really quick
did you actually see this [ __ ] or you
just [ __ ] bullshitted me now i kind
of want to see it yeah now i kind of
want to see it the dude
no i don't i'm old my
although there were some there was some
[ __ ] dude there were some [ __ ]
asylum films that were [ __ ] good like
uh nazis at the center of the earth i
liked it it was [ __ ] really good it
was like now and then they kind of like
get a good
sometimes they [ __ ] come up sometimes
because that'll just like oh mostly it's
just kind of like they're like well
whatever the big thing is we're gonna
make a like a cheap knockout yeah but
you know but no [ __ ] nazis at the
center of the earth was [ __ ] over the
top it was like up there with [ __ ]
with velocipaster it was like that oh i
don't know about that i mean
it's a lot better but like i said
velocipaster was kind of like
the platonic ideal yeah
of
shitty movies like it it's kind of like
the venn diagram of like shitty movies
on this side
and enjoyable movies on this side it was
like
it was like the perfect
man it was like the perfect [ __ ]
balance khan says he hasn't seen it yet
he's got it [ __ ] downloaded on hd
2018 which a lot of people did not yeah
it was much it was much better than um
than [ __ ] uh candyman 2 is a lot
better
it's a different movie it's a different
movie but much better
yeah i like handyman one i thought candy
land was actually masterpiece candyman 2
is kind of dull
i mean it had some good stuff in it
uh but that watching watching candyman 2
what's the real name of it
i'm calling it candy it's just called
candy just come on cam
it let me know how much how much [ __ ]
todd has to be in that damn movie if you
ask me it really rides off like i said i
kind of feel like tony todd is so
awesome
that
anyone that has to follow that yeah
it's not going to be so i know tila
probably missed our other show a couple
days back
seeing the remake of night of the living
dead with tony todd starring he played
ben in it and we did a review of it a
couple days back
that kind of made up for [ __ ] candy
man too
see
night of the living dead 1990 1990
nineteen yeah natalie tom savini tom
sabine
tony todd starring it's one of his best
movies
oh i thought you were gonna no
[Laughter]
he always seems like he's going to keep
talking
he doesn't keep talking
uh you know all right so how long have
we gone god dude it says tom hates candy
man 20 yeah i didn't like it i didn't
like it i thought it lacked i didn't
mind i love it but
it was okay it lacked the charm of the
original and it just it it let it it
really showed me how much candy man
really depends on tony todd
without tony todd you don't really have
that movie
and you don't have that character and i
just thought the writing was bad and it
was just
it was just kind of lackluster you know
what i mean it just needed a better
script
that
but the way it was shot was pretty good
it just is kind of meandering and kind
of
[ __ ] characters and
it just it was just mediocre
i would say
i would say because
the first candyman was so strong
i thought because this one wasn't as
good it was kind of a bigger letdown
it'd be like having a [ __ ] really
good alien one and then kind of a
mediocre alien too imagine if that would
happen even though i know there were
some other movies in between i didn't
see him
i didn't see him i only saw the first
one
and i saw that one and i was like
well like i said in some ways it's kind
of like shitty if you make a like a
movie that's like so awesome yeah it's
like now we're gonna make another one
and it's like it's never going to be as
good
as the first one and it's never going to
be as good oh and what was what was
frustrating about it is that parts of it
were really good
like certain elements yeah there were
like some actually great yeah yeah but
it didn't gel into a single experience
that was like oh that was a good movie
you know what i mean just it just didn't
tila asks have we watched squid game yes
we have yeah it was pretty good um
actually yeah i really liked that i
liked like the first couple episodes and
then it kind of got slow in the middle
but then like at the end yeah i was
really into like the last couple
episodes i liked the beginning and the
end yeah couple that stuff in the middle
like the middle stuff was good too but
like not as good but like the middle
like the beginning and the end were like
really really good and i like the fact
that the koreans knew they were kind of
on something or on to something because
they left it open for another season
which i would totally watch that yeah
and they have to [ __ ] up their game
okay this
the series game requires [ __ ]
endurance yeah when it comes to writing
you have to be able to write
progressively interesting [ __ ] over and
over again
which i kind of think the first season
didn't do
halfway through the season it started to
be like this is not that interesting
but then it got better it's kind of like
they saw the mistake that they were
making
it tried to make it too
normal
i think
it started backing off of some of the
absurdity or the bizarreness of the
first few episodes i wanted to just
continue to turn it up and turn it up
and turn it up kind of the way kind of
like the first like
four seasons of the walking dead did
they just kept turning it up
you know
then that started to peter out
no seas no
very difficult for a [ __ ] series to
hang on through well it's kind of hard
to like keep like sustained [ __ ] over
that long of a time the best long term
series was dexter really one of the best
ones [ __ ] it helped yeah we gotta see
that new [ __ ] because they've like done
dexter held out for a long time and i
liked that florida feel to it
i was like yeah that's south florida and
it just kind of
it did well i mean yeah some people say
well it kind of got a little weak as it
went on and they killed some of their
main character well they were trying to
wrap it up
a lot of people got mad that they killed
some of the favorite characters out of
it but that's the way that had to go i
want to see that again actually
well we should probably rewatch it yeah
before we watch that new season yeah i
was kind of like the new season is out
already
um it might be i saw some ads for it
so it's either out or it's coming out
yeah um she's also asking about uh
midnight mass which i still need to
watch that that's mike flanagan same guy
that did dr sleep same guy that did
haunting of hill house haunting blind
banner all that kind of stuff so i've
been like meaning to watch that but i
haven't watched it yet so
i will get to it i promise but i haven't
had a lot of time this week
so
i will pro i will get to it i promise oh
i'm going red i'm going red yeah it went
back yellow
okay
the little [ __ ] went red but you know
yeah it's either said koreans are
killing it in my opinion jenny said the
same thing
i mean all their [ __ ] lately has been
really really good yeah i think we're i
think we're ducking out yeah i lost my
connection over here
well yeah like i said in there it's
green there but it went like red and
orange just for a second i'll repeat
what i said kanavasan says midnight mass
is great yeah i
i really need to watch that that's going
to be my next like long-term thing yeah
okay let me answer uh louie uh halloween
kills i liked it i liked it i did it as
well i thought it was better than the
last halloween um
and then uh
tina says the koreans are killing it in
my opinion trying to boost on was really
good yeah
jenny said the same thing the koreans
are killing it uh yeah they're getting
into the series game yeah
also can we talk about like even go back
a few years like look at movies like the
host or like the whaling or
man [ __ ] like that like their [ __ ] was
like way better than
the american [ __ ] that was going on at
the same time they're talking about how
good midnight mass is i don't even know
that when i ever heard of it yeah well
like i said it's mike flanagan same guy
that did haunting hill house he did dr
sleep he did all that kind of stuff i
probably like it though so i really
liked dr sleep
the extended version that you get on the
home blu-ray yeah see the director's cut
of dr sleep that's better than the
original yeah a lot more in it oh we're
going red again let me go ahead and shut
it down here once this comes back yeah i
guess we should all right all right are
we going as good as this back green
again
tila says also you on netflix is
supposed to be interesting yeah i've
heard about that too so we should watch
that also looks like we're kind of like
cutting out
and we're pretty drunk okay get my
hamburger on and hungry yeah so
we will be back on sunday sunday
we should do like a halloween show
they're saying that titus says that i'll
dig this midnight mass
okay we'll check it out i'm looking
forward to it good i've been saving it
okay
we'll watch it all right
i'm looking forward to it so we'll see
uh camp guy says you is awesome one of
the best i've ever seen
okay
is it good man we're so drunk yeah
all right so we'll be back on sunday
which is actual halloween day thank you
for the super chats people thank you for
stupid jazz thank you for hanging out
with us yeah we've had a really good
time tonight yeah have a good [ __ ]
set of friday night go ahead and
continue to drink and watch your [ __ ]
and it's like it will be probably back
sunday yeah
yeah sunday we're back sunday sunday is
halloween yeah
gotta go get some candy
get some candy yeah get some costumes
all right we're gonna have a fun time
okay on sunday
so we will see you guys on sunday
and thank you for dropping by thank you
for all your contributions
we will see you guys sunday
bye
see you next